while the afternoon something we were
looking at was ok let's come back all
the way to beginning on this topic right
as tuna students we know that we can
express the volume of a solid of
revolution in what way as a gene its tip
where you're at I'll give you a clue it
starts like this from A to B of what ok
as an example this is where we begin
right and this is a simple extension of
an area underneath the curve so when
you're thinking underneath you're
comparing to the x-axis aren't you so
that's why we begin here but then we
extend that we say hey if you can do it
around this axis is the reason why you
can't go around this axis you get x
squared dy no dramas ok so this is where
it begins but we open the hood right and
we said yeah what's really going on
under huge and we said actually what
this DX disguises is that there's this
Delta X which is getting very very
little right so we said this is really
the limit as X approaches zero off and
it's a song on the same boundaries of
what what are we adding up what we're
dealing with you what you're dealing
with here is a series of so there's all
of these particular cylinders because
you're going around the x-axis they're
all this way so they're with is Delta X
it's a width like this and this is the
volume of the sword we said hey look you
know what once you understand that you
can tease this apart you can change the
shape the the slices that you're adding
up you can have angular slices you can
change this not a reason why you have to
be limited here or here right you can go
off in any direction you like in Gotham
angle etc we saw at the moment this is
just limited to slicing perpendicular to
the axis of rotation but if we want to
we can go parallel sorry parallel to the
axis of rotation and that gives you
cylindrical shells ok but as we
established every single volume that
we've been looking at always has this
and that's because these are all volumes
for x well circular kind of things
cylindrical shells annulus lines now all
about rotation right all of these kinds
of shapes despite all of the things that
we've changed they're all formed by
rotation in someone ok so we're
extension two volumes ends is to say
well what if it's not by rotation right
now here's an important shape I need you
to draw and it's the one we kind of
started building yesterday we're
actually going to go into and we're
going to make a more 3d day going what
we've done the past so we've done
usually is we just have our normal
coordinate axes and then we kind of look
on to that and we superimpose something
on that so we can kind of imagine okay
but for these kinds of volumes that's
not going to cut it okay so what I want
you to draw is an XY plane but viewed
from an angle so imagine your XY plane
kind of a round so here's an X plane ok
an x-axis rather and I don't have
another meter rule so here's the y-axis
and we're looking at it we're looking at
from above it's sitting flat on the
ground ok so let's actually label the
actions as such cool here we go we'll
keep will maintain the x-axis be
horizontal ok but here's our y-axis
which we usually think of is just going
up ok it's going off into the distance
ok that means there actually is a
vertical axis here I'm not going to draw
in there we don't need it we just have
to get an idea what's going on ok so
this shape that we were looking at
yesterday where it begins is to say
alright start with an excuse me a
circular base now if I were looking at
this bang on it would just be a circle
equal radius but because I'm off and
angles what you get going to get will be
kind of elliptical ok so you're going to
get something sort of roughly like that
ok so this is actually a circle but
we're looking at it from an angle now do
you remember what we did to create all
of these guys
right is that these cylinders came from
strips that were then rotated right
strips that were rotated so here I'll I
do the same thing in terms of
considering a strip right something like
say there's no one axis of rotation for
me to be perpendicular or parallel to
because instead of creating our volume
by rotating I'm going to take this strip
and make it the base in this particular
case of a square prism so square prism
so what I want is this is going to come
up into the air okay so to try and make
it as realistic as possible you might
like to use a ruler to try and get these
distances right this is roughly where
I'm going to be
okay so in the past we had cylindrical
shells we had annular slices this is a
square slice okay I've cut across here
and I'm taking the width of this chord
right and making that the side length of
my sweat okay as you can see and it's a
bit hard because the more of these you
draw the more cloud of your diagram
becomes because we're just kind of
putting things on top of one of them
you're going to get a shape I mean for
example you can draw this slice probably
this one over here this is going to be a
much smaller square yes so be something
like this and you've got a whole bunch
of these added up together yeah there's
nothing I try to stay to approximate as
best as we possibly could it's quite
difficult obviously so i listed a little
bit of help and a function this is not
finished but it'll still do don't worry
up in a second this is the kind of shape
we're looking at okay now I want you to
see and unfortunately to make it a
little clearer to see this diagram is
not complete but you've got enough into
shape for me to talk about me if you're
to look for if I'm going to get the
light if you were to a position yourself
no vertically right at the top right
like hovering like in a helicopter right
above the middle of this shape okay if
you were to that look down at the shape
can you see this excuse me this readout
like yeah see that red outline that's
forming the circle that's the base okay
so on profile that's what you're seeing
okay but when you step back even though
it's just circular like that you're not
just getting a nice neat door that's a
hemisphere okay because we used squares
all the way through you get all these
square these flat edges here and this is
this out I think the rafter were used
was a ridge but I think ridge is exactly
right you've got this part that's coming
up from all of the corners of your
squares right as this would come down
where would this end as as these ridges
come all the way down they're going to
end on the x-axis aren't they do you see
they're all going to come down and
eventually there will be square
here that has or has that width right
because it's right at the corner of the
round part does that make sense so this
is the kind of shape that we've got this
is a visualization